برده احنا اللي علينا انه عيد اا النظر في
كل شيء نكون فكرنا فيه واملنا به نظريا
ولم تصدق عليه التجربه يعني لا ما انا
مثلا ابقى مؤمن بانه همم اذا قامت الثوره
فنقول له العمال همم ابقوا في المصانع
وسيطروا على ادارتها ومن هنا تبدا الثوره
فتقول لهم كده فما يعملوش كده ويقولوا لك
الميدان التحرير قلت له ايه بقى تقول له
مثلا
ولا انت اللي تغير الدماغك انت بتغير
دماغك ثم جربنا هو انا قلت
تغيير هو التغيير بالقوه القوه دي بيننا
نضرب بعض في الاخر خلاص خطوه واحده هنضرب
بعض بالنار
ايه بقى المفروض ان انا اعمل ايه او خطوه
واحده وهنبتدي نضرب في الجيش لما حد يعمل
كده المفروض اعمل ايه
انا مش عارف فرق هنا كبيره تقول لا احنا
مش متخلف السياسه انت بتهد بلد في فرق
كبير اهدي طبقه غير الهد بلدي
فانت تجربه متعلمه انه لا انا النهارده في
موقع شايف فيه انه احنا ماشيين منه
انا ما بيفرقش معي تقصر عليه لان انا كنت
بنزل كمعارض من ايام ما كنا بتبقى الوزاره
200 نفر وبتضرب انا ما بيحركليش مصالحي
الحرامي اللي في الاول ما بدي اذا اقتنع
هانزله ثم احنا مش في موضوع المرسومين
الشعب الجيل ده من الشعب ده قد الاتنين
رؤساء المحاكم الله يرحم الجميع وقدم عدد
من الوزراء ويقدر يشتغل في اي وقت لكن
احنا مش عايزين نعمل ده لان احنا شايفين
ان احنا ماشيين في اتجاه مرهق بس ان شاء
الله في النتيجه ليه
اليوم نقدر الفنان المصري يحكي عن
عن حياه الشارع المصري الازمه الاقتصاديه
مثلا ارتفاع على اسعار الامور
السياسيه وغيرها ولا مش المفروض تتكلم
عنها
حتى تقول لك
وهكذا لكن
يصوب وخصام ولا تعريب وفي كل الاحوال كل
بلد من البلدان العربيه على قد ما احنا
اخوات كل اساس لها
طيب عشان دخل